hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost delights okay we're
making our way looking for some switches
and someone mentioned that I didn't
check everywhere upstairs so I need to
go up the stairs and up another level to
see if there are more rooms up there
which probably have switches hopefully I
keep going into other games like I just
I just got off my livestream and like
you know I was just doing Max Payne and
you know I'm thinking uh Herpa derpa
derpa oh yeah I'm playing this game now
oh yeah see there wasn't there wasn't
you're all liars you're all liars there
was not another level so the switches
are in this room this is the room where
that switch was and that does nothing
because I haven't quite gotten quite and
gotten I haven't quite gotten gather
floating candlestick haunted kins
nothing up there nothing in here
nope nope nope
[Music]
okay I figure there won't be another
switch in the room with the switch so
have I even gone in here maybe maybe
there's something else bright and shiny
but nothing else nope okay there's
nothing whole lotta nothin whole bunch
up nothing
so in here there's nothing in there
why but but ah it could be something
else somewhere else nope it's all a lie
why my whole life
floating candlestick floating
candlestick loading candlestick using up
all my huh
fine anything up up here
come on was this fricking switch looking
I'm looking I'm looking I'm not seeing
wasting oil all right let me think you
don't know what the hell this is but I
remember like a long time ago in the
beginning of this let's play someone
said I needed a glass jar to get acid so
I don't know gather I mean excuse me
chair I'm sorry okay so there I look
through all that room I looked through
everywhere in that room and there was
nothing so it has to be in either of
these rooms that's what that that's what
the thing said right no mementos but a
note said the instructions that's not it
no it's not it either
where did it go okay here they go
there are three levers - in each room
lovers duck - in each room wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
- third lovers stuck when you found all
levers and pulled it third will be
unstuck - - and each room would suggest
that there's two in every room but I'm
not counting on this guys English here
I'm assuming he means - in the rooms you
know I just wish it wasn't so Frick
fricky dark that he used my lantern to
look in all the corners there was
nothing in here I've already searched
everywhere it's just there's nothing
here nothing it's just nothing all there
- get open oh man shouldn't be this
difficult or I should be smarter one of
the two I don't know whichever one you
want to make it whichever one seems more
fair you want to make this let easier or
me smarter
I don't like being lost that's one of my
least favorite things in games I know it
happens a lot but I really really
dislike being lost because it totally
breaks the atmosphere breaks the
progress I'm making and it means that I
go a long time without anything
interesting happening scares no nothing
nothing there don't check up all above
the bed yep
nothing nothing nothing nothing
absolutely nothing okay I'm lost I'm
like let me go doc downstairs there's
something down there that I missed hmm
dislike dislike dislike
oh crap oh crap oh crap
ah you gotta be kidding me you've you
gotta be kidding me you gotta be kidding
me
you gotta be kidding me
fudge fudge fudge
ah okay whatever whatever it's fine I
didn't make any progress anyway so it's
not like I needed to save
okay back down here I'm back downstairs
that's upstairs
there was nothing in any of these when
those candlesticks is a switch
no no at least now I didn't waste all my
will but I still haven't found anything
I haven't found anything at all bullcrap
- in each room Oh three levers - in each
room third lever is unstuck I don't know
I don't know I don't know the thing is
the lever that I found up here it's
clearly marked it as a torch inside of
the the boudoir the ah wha sorry as a
torch in here illuminating the switch so
I would assume that any other would be
well you know lit this also the fact
that I can't see [ __ ] is bothersome
we go back downstairs or something I
don't know gah ah what okay this is the
lever that's stuck okay
all right so she's behind the painting
find the painting ah yes ah behind the
picture yes oh my goodness
I got it I got it I got it I got it
click and then okay I now click both
levers now this one will be unstuck okay
all right maybe not maybe not maybe I
hit the other one okay ah ah ah painting
painting panics always behind the
painting and hit this one
okay now unstuck yeah [ __ ] it now it
only goes up okay what am I doing wrong
here what am i doing wrong those were
two switches who switches don't seem to
be doing anything come on I got this Oh
what do you want from me
there any paintings in the the ones
downstairs I don't know I don't know
it's not time thing because I went right
from one to the other and then maybe
maybe it is I'll try it as soon as I
look for paintings hmm hate this I miss
puzzles and this game was going so well
I had such high hopes for this this
custom story
it's got throw this at me maybe it's my
fault
I don't think so all right let me try
next thing is gonna hit one go straight
to the other hit that and then go
straight to the one maybe it is a time
thing I didn't hear any clicks but
whatever whatever go straight from this
one straight to the other okay good
chunk go go go come on
okay Kurt chunk and then nothing
I'm guessing oh no I'm on the wrong side
house
I'll probably wasted time going the
wrong way
Oh am I doing wrong trying to pull it
down but even when I just click on it
and I don't do anything it just goes up
oh man
it's killing me this is killing me this
is killing me maybe the other way that
the other one only goes down really come
on now show me the money show me the
money
do anything Oh maybe ah ah ah come on no
no no no no no no no no no what the hell
what the hell
Oh close aren't you going oh what the
hell
painting painting painting
my goodness okay I didn't know where it
was coming from I didn't know it's
coming straight ahead of me all right
finally finally I'm making some progress
oh man that was the worst okay I guess I
did
beating on the door
alright looks clear
ah alright cool
damn finally that took a long time to
make progress enter the forbidden hotel
floor let's go
I'm not scared not even a little bit
I'm old now let's go let's go somewhere
that do something come on come on let's
go let's go oh my god this place feels
so evil was this really a good idea to
go in here complete your sentence spider
welcome to the Great Hall where your
wishes come true huh not really this is
a forbidden hotel floor congratulations
you're a dick well it certainly doesn't
look good
someone needs to clean this place up
it's awfully dark crap I'm gonna run out
of oil I really I'm gonna run out of oil
you're watching me well I'm watching you
too
oh hello whoo aha oh no we had to hide
David because see man wanted him to die
see men is a powerful man or something
see man was not visible to our eyes but
many people didn't listen to him and
they eventually died in their sleep
okay and the point of this was Oh
painting got ya Oh skiers need to be
greased really whatever fine anything
else behind these paintings
what's that painting someone's watching
me and I gotta find some grease whoo
more painting oh that was nothing troll
troll painting oil torches torches
torches this is going on here what is
this
that's strange is it a map might be a
map I'm sort of a map no oil rig Iraq
actually I'm all out of time oh well oh
I'll figure this out later thanks you
guys so much for watching and bearing
with me through that awful puzzle back
there but anyway thanks again for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next part bye bye